in
franken washington oregon arizona nevada
everywhere you name it i know
i stayed in 17 missions in the united
states i'll save more jails you can say
shake a stick at
i think something else blew your mind i
don't think that's getting angry when
you ask about it
i caught 46 felonies and three bandos in
two days
two or three days like that yeah
46 felonies you imagine that
we would you say the the four days
you've been awake the longest 49 49 days
no sleep no sleep
no
that's crazy no sleep at all what were
you like after 49 days of not sleeping
well what what were you like after 49
days uh i was ha
i stayed hot so i got back to huntington
but you don't get like psychosis or
anything crazy
no i get horny
that's what i get
these is that or i just get hyper to
walk
and i walk
so you've walked a lot oh yeah i walk so
much put blisters on my feet
feet be bleeding when i walk from here
to when i walk from here los angeles
i done
probably about 70 80 units out of ice
i was up and i took off walking
you walked from west virginia to
california west virginia to los angeles
california 42 days and 41 nights walking
walking no hitchhiking no hitchhiking no
rides
eight ball or a half ounce of ice in my
pocket 25 needles in my pocket my water
and about 500
how about it take you
how long did it take you 42 days
and 41 nights
to get from here to los angeles
downtown los angeles where i stayed up
for three days
and then took off and walked from there
to san diego
stayed in san diego for four days and
then hit arizona
then i went to nevada
then i went to utah then i went to work
but walking i walked all i had all of
them stay ahead
california utah arizona
oregon
wisconsin i was down there
i was on
south dakota north dakota
uh
massachusetts i was everywhere you've
been to every state every state yeah
except for hawaii because i wasn't
swimming
all right so lurch and amber
um where'd you guys grow up where are
you from originally
i'm from right here in huntington west
virginia huntington and amber where are
you from
huntington you're both from huntington
how did you grow up there she had mom
and dad i'm not good i have real life
uh see i was raped
by my grandfather two grandfathers my
uncle my dad repeatedly from time i was
from time i was born up till i was five
years old
repeatedly three times a day
and then on top of that i've been beat
with switches
extension cords
willow switches
uh you name it got hit for two by four
ball bat i have a brother shoot at me my
mom tried to kill me
my sister put decon in my eggs i've been
lifting quicksand up to my neck
oh yeah i've been shot at i've been
stabbed
in all this time were you living today
you're on the street yeah
i got kicked out last night
so you're you're living on the street
here in huntington yep and all i'll do
is be walking and doing this i'll relax
and you miss today
because i'll be walking
and amber what what's your story you
grew up where i mean how you had mom and
dad
do you have a mom and dad
um do i have a mom and dad
yeah
i'm adopted also oh you were
you guys have been a couple for how long
yeah three years three years
so amber your your childhood how would
you describe it
how would you describe your childhood
um
my childhood it was okay it was good my
parents was good christian people
so growing up all the way until 23
it was pretty good and then what
happened at 23.
i started i
started smoking and doing drugs okay
and lurch you started when
oh i started
drugs when i was about 13 years old i
started out on a cocaine and pcp and
angel dust
13. yeah and then i went into the
percocets the oxycontin
the openers and all that for about 10 or
15 years and then when i took my little
boy from me i hit methane heroin
and fentanyl
so you're hardcore yeah
i've been in
jail in every state united states
huntington morning you shake a stick at
i've got like i told you i caught 46
felonies
in less than three days from bando
that's daytime burglary nighttime
burglary criminal trespassing
but when they try to charge me with it
and went to court
judge said i like a total judge if you
don't press charges on me you gotta get
the rest of the homeless people they
dropped it
and then all the sicknesses i have to go
with all this
i'm a walking time bomb tell me about
your health my health i have hiv
i have pestd i have schizophrenic i have
paranoia i'm mentally sick i'm mentally
ill my hands and feet are rushed
homicidal suicidal
i can kill you at any given time i get
by with it you seem very healthy though
i am on the outside but the inside no
my heart you went from good to bad like
that how are you how old am i 48 48 and
feel like i'm about 22 23
[Music]
i feel like i could kill the world hiv
you picked that up how huh how did you
pick up hiv sharon needles didn't know
it then the person had it
i know the person that gave it to me
but i'm not worried about them hiv is
very common here in huntington 80 of
huntington has hiv i'm sorry
80 of huntington has hiv
20 of the 80 is teenagers
we've had okay 2017 a lot of people i
mean y'all might know this y'all might
not because it was on the world news
back in 2017
huntington was rated number one in the
nation and the united states for more
heroin and obesity
and overdoses
like when january 1 of 2017 first hit
all the way up until january the 16th
there was over 600 overdoses in west
virginia
fentanyl heroin and meth
you voted as well have you odd i've od
17 times
this one right here brought me back four
months and 21 days ago that was the last
time we'd done it when she brought me
back off of metal fentanyl and doing a
seven year i done a 70 unit shot
five minutes later oh being honest after
i've done a shot i started sweating you
know i started sweating really bad i was
like my whole shirt was wet
then i lost my vision for two minutes
then i lost my hearing for two minutes
then my dick got hard and i died
if it wasn't for her i'd still be dead
and then everybody says we don't care
love each other harmony house he's been
trying to break us up for three years
they said i forced her to do dope i
forced her to have sex we've had sex
four times in three years
i'm not forcing i'm just not trying to
get i wasn't trying to give her my
disease yeah amber you're how old are
you
she's 34. you're 34. i can't tell if
you're 14 or
12 people she's my daughter but she's my
woman 34. now and do you have kids amber
do you have children yeah children one
a little boy and are you raising him
are you raising him
um from birth to
i say about four
her dad has them but she gives
visitation to him
and i don't try to i don't blend in with
it you know i'm saying i don't
when she has her visitations with her
little boy i stay back
let her have her quality time i get her
quality time anytime i want it so
there's you seem like an expert on the
huntington drug situation what what do
you think the reason that
drug addiction is so prevalent here
well
because the way everybody's attitudes
are people disrespect you when you're
homeless
out here on the street all you get is
disrespect not just from the police
department but your
courthouse
your individuals like
you or me out here and we're not doing
dope you get disrespected by anybody and
everybody out here so drugs yeah where's
everybody go drugs because
when people disrespect you or hurt your
feelings
the drugs is what's there for you no one
else is there
i don't have a care in the world no more
i have been put down past five years
even though me has been struggling i
have went down i've lost seven bags of
clothes i've lost five pairs of shoes
i've lost my home
lost everything i would think when you
sleep you sleep for three days no
about six or seven hours don't they
better i sleep about six or seven hours
when i do go to sleep yeah and so today
you're using math
i will be when i live here yeah
because i have like i said i got kicked
out i'm gonna be on the street walking
all night
and when you're walking out here on the
street you can't sit down nowhere if you
do you get a ticket or go to jail you
can't lay down nowhere if you do you get
a ticket or go to jail you even have
somebody out here for a cigarette or
change or whatever to get something to
eat or drink you're going to jail
regardless
you pick up a dirty needle you're going
to jail you pick up any kind of
paraphernalia you're going to jail when
you're homeless you're going to jail
they're trying to put a law out here now
to where
if you have a backpack you're going to
jail
amber amber what
tell me your current drug
situation your current drug situation of
what you like to do and stuff
what i like to do is
i don't like to do it now but
what i used to do is heroin
and i did it for a year and a half
and then i got
i met this guy and i got clean
for like two years
and then i started back and i od'd and
lost my home my car my son
that's the way it felt
and so currently you're using but i'm
better now
are you using anything now
we're working on getting a little boy
back for i'm going to get my voucher up
to get a two-bedroom put her name on the
leash just so she can have her son she's
only in one bedroom
but i have heart for her
i don't have it for anybody else
no one not even harming house not i
don't have heart for harmony house i
don't have heart for city mission
the only way that i would piss foot
harming house if they cut on fire the
courthouse caught on fire city mission
caught on fire the only way i'd help put
that fire out is if i was fishing c4
gasoline
with them in it so tell me about uh you
have hopes of getting perfectly clean to
me
both of you oh yeah it will happen one
day but like i tell everybody okay
we put god first like you're coming
clean
it worked she was an iq shelter
and here's the hard part part believing
about me
when we first started becoming clean
i was out here on the street walking
around
but i still wasn't doing dope so i could
be with my woman i've had harmony house
and all these other people call her and
tell her hey he relapsed no i didn't my
kidney shut down because the harmony
house the mission or no one around here
would give me anything to eat or drink
what i want completely
no dope no suboxone no drinks at all
period and no food for two weeks my
kidneys shut down to snake eyes i was in
hospital for a week they called her told
her i relapsed [ __ ] union relapse
i didn't relapse i had nothing to eat
and nothing to drink and i ask you and
all you people are supposed to give me
food and drink y'all wouldn't
well i've been trying to get my social
security card my birth certificate my
voucher and some stuff i took up there
to her for past six months they won't
give it to me i asked you this question
before but let me ask you a different
way uh
what what causes so many young people to
get into drugs in this part of the
country mostly young people
for one there's nothing here to do like
there is in l.a i'm saying like in l.a
you could take your kids and go watch a
nba basketball game or a baseball game
somewhere or nfl team playing or a
concert there's nothing in huntington
but dope
only thing you're going to get out of
hands in west virginia or west virginia
period is dope and heart agent that's
all you're going to get here we are the
lowest state for anything jobs anything
that's why you got young people
coming out here to cylinder and not only
they selling it now they're using them
poverty is a big part of the future
yeah i mean because if you actually look
at it even on you google it up yourself
on the phone
west virginia's the lowest state for
jobs and everything that's why you got
all your young you got people kids
starting at 11 12 years old packing nine
millimeters and selling selenites and
heroin
why they doing that to support their
family because their mom and dad
know
they're barely making ends meet to pay
rent why do you think she's out here
doing it
raising people like me are doing that
where do the drugs come from
different places la
detroit
uh
new mexico and about anywhere anywhere
and everywhere you got detroit and
atlanta comes in here twice a day
dropping off methane heroin from
greyhound or wherever what percentage of
the like people in their 20s 30s 40s are
addicted to drugs here
i can't judge no one for that so i
probably wouldn't be able to answer that
because i'm an addict myself
so i'm not going to judge no one else
i'm not going to say nothing about no
one else even i can't say nothing about
if you're doing dope you're doing it i
wish you wouldn't
if you lived a life like i have and my
girl has
no i wouldn't do no dope at all
it's all dope is
okay if you smoke it you burn your
nostrils up if you snort it you're
crystallizing your lungs if you're
shooting it you're [ __ ] your veins up
all you're doing is killing yourself
slowly
sometimes quickly depends on what you're
doing but no don't do dope
hook up if you want to get high get high
on god
and my woman that's what i got home
i don't get my little boy back i'll
never see my little boy again i had him
by myself for 10 years didn't even do
dope until then
lost him got her two years later i'll
never see my son i get to talk to him
here and there but i'm good
what's your biggest regret nurturing
what's my biggest regret being on earth
you ask i'm being honest with you
i've had 48 years of abuse and use and
i'm done
my own family the ones even brought me
up here
all they've done is used me abusing me
they call me when they want something i
knew something if i needed to want it
[ __ ] you go get you a job
okay i'll remember that
you feel abandoned by your like let down
oh i feel that don't ever your family
yeah the only family i have the way i
see it in life right now the only family
i have is this woman right here this one
that's my best friend that's my wife
soon to be wife that's my friend said
she's everything to me
she's my backbone
and how about you amber you have family
or do you have anyone
he said do you have family or anyone um
just my son
my biological family don't talk to me
it's just me and her
i mean we do get along with my mom and
in but we don't you know i'm saying
we go over and visit with them hang out
with them much we can
my brother was against it because we're
using the needle
i can understand that
i can
so we don't
know and tonight even when i go to do
something i'll probably snort it or
smoke it i'm not shooting
if i shoot then my girl won't see me for
14 or 15 days i'll be off somewhere
walking and forget that where she lives
so no i'm not shooting
what's the worst your drug use has
gotten what's what what's what's the
most extreme your drug use is the most
extreme like the most i've ever done or
whatever i've done
me and her together
this is right before we quit right
before od we done
two balls of heroin and two balls of
mess a piece in three days
two balls a piece
and that was an equivalent of maybe
five shots maybe six tops we did a lot
i've had close to
i don't know an ounce and a half of meth
that my mom's in me and her go through
it in five six days 130 140 regs
i'd have to go back three times a week
just to get rigs
and then i was not just that i was going
huntington
charleston west virginia i leave
huntington i go to charleston that's uh
i'll take her with me that'd be eight
more packs of rigs there we'll go to
ashland get eight more packs
but then by the end of the week
all of them's dirty every one of them
do you feel like you have a death wish
does wish yeah
i just want to be dead
no the only person who really teaches me
alive out here is this woman right here
other than that i would be dead
i've got 17 but i'm here for a reason
that's why i quit dope
how many people you know gonna die 17
times in five years and still be able to
talk into that camera right there i
don't do any but me with hiv huh with
hiv you're correct yeah how do you stay
so healthy
i eat right i don't need dope i don't do
no dope whatsoever right now
but
what about meth huh what about the mess
i ain't messing with another four months
and 20 days
tonight probably the first night but i
don't know i haven't wanted it but like
i say
i'm gonna be hunting walking all night
long i can't sit down nowhere
i can't lay down nowhere i won't have no
money to eat on
i will
but i'll get meds to keep me walking
as long as i'm walking
lol don't mess with you because i'm
walking
here's what most
people get high mess up at
they stay around
from campus here in huntington
downtown campus at 16th street side all
the way far west end
me and i was walking yesterday housing
there was five rigs laying there i said
nope i'm not picking them up because
it's 185 dollars for each one you pick
up
so somebody out here gonna catch a
disease if they ain't careful and i'm
not i'm i can't afford i don't work
right now i don't have no id
you've had jobs i have a job i just got
to get the id before i could start
it's going to be my first job in five
years
texas roadhouse eleven dollars an hour
that's what i don't want to do
like i told her i don't need all this
myth here with a
big old blunt we go to work 40 hours a
week put us in a home we're good to go
and getting clean is
you know no suboxone nothing like that
no it's boxing none
we haven't even been dope [ __ ]
that's the good thing
smoke a little weed drink a few beers
there's nothing wrong with that american
people do it anyway
most people's already
everybody's at least tried beer
marijuana if they don't do it don't
judge me because god put it here do you
feel like the uh
the childhood trauma the use you went
through as a kid yeah is what led you
here no no my childhood stuff i had
that's on the way up to the day
the abuse and stuff i get okay like for
instance
uh you're my family you know i'm
homeless on the street
i had 329 in food stamps i spent 200 on
you and asked if i could stay for two
days you say no but you kept my food and
you know i'm homeless now now i have
nothing
and you put me back on the street
that abuse goes on today
the only person i don't have have in my
life don't abuse me there's this woman
right here
i get more respect from her caring from
her love from her honest from her not do
anybody in the united states anybody
so my heart goes on every day i'm badly
depressed
i got pressed air want to put me on
ten zen x bars and five volume tens a
day
they want to take 1500 pills a day and
i'd still look at them like i'm looking
at you right now
they had me a straight jacket two years
ago
i was only on a straight jacket for
three seconds i come right out of it
he how do you do that wouldn't you like
to know it's confidential like a tape
didn't have to kill you when i'm done
when my son died in 2009
i got really high on percocets and
xanaxes
last thing i remember was putting a
security guard at capitol huntington
through a two and a half inch thick door
with my bare hand how did you lose your
son
uh his mom beat herself in the stomach
so she wouldn't have the delivery
three weeks before delivery
come out five pounds seven ounces 26
inches long i had to cut the cord i went
crazy
yeah i've had a bad life
well like i said doing a good part but
my life is when i met her and been with
her that's the only thing given my
life's ever happened except me having
something but then i lost him
what would you say is the the most
important thing you've learned in your
life
march what's the most important thing
i've ever learned in life
you're getting with her
that's up honestly i'm getting with this
one right here
that was her
now like i said we've been four months
20 days i might not even go ahead and do
noise i got hurt in my life
i get high i just think i got god
i'm a woman what else do i need
all right lurch and amber thank you so
much for sharing your stories
i wish you guys the best of luck
you